y
[Música]
el presidente de francia de manuel macro
dio positivo por coronavirus tras
presentar algunos síntomas el palacio
del elíseo indicó que aún no se conoce
cómo contrajo la enfermedad y estará
aislado durante siete días el primer
ministro fran castex dio negativo en su
prueba tenemos información desde parís
en las últimas 24 horas eeuu rompió sus
récords de contagios y muertes con más
de 250.000 nuevos positivos y más de
3500 fallecimientos en las próximas
horas un comité de asesores de la
administración de medicamentos y
alimentos se reunirá para analizar la
vacuna del laboratorio moderna que se
espera reciba la aprobación de
emergencia en los próximos días
brasil el país más afectado de américa
latina por el coronavirus superó los 7
millones de casos el mismo día en que el
presidente ya ha ir bolsonaro presentó
su ambicioso plan de vacunación que
buscará inmunizar a sus 210 millones de
ciudadanos en 16 meses
gracias por continuar con nosotros aquí
en france24 soy valentina torre sánchez
iniciamos este informativo en francia
porque el palacio del elíseo confirmó
que el presidente francés emmanuel
makoun dio positivo por coronavirus el
gobierno señaló que tras reportar
síntomas
el mandatario fue sometido a una prueba
y permanecerá siete días aislado aún no
se conoce como cómo contrajo la
enfermedad
el anuncio desencadenó una serie de
medidas preventivas la primera dama
brigitte macrón y el presidente del
gobierno español pedro sánchez se
aislarán preventivamente el primer
ministro jan castex dio negativo al
virus conectamos con nuestra periodista
en parís natalia ruiz
natalia buenos días que datos
adicionales se conocen hasta el momento
hay otros líderes que vayan a aislarse
después de este positivo de manuel macro
muy buenos días pues y poco a poco
después de que se dio a conocer esta
noticia en un comunicado como se lo
decía muy escueto por parte del inicio
son cada vez más las personas que se van
a poner en cuarentena preventivamente
porque la agenda del presidente macon
durante toda esta semana había estado
bastante apretada el lunes precisamente
en ese encuentro con pedro sánchez pero
el martes el almuerzo con el presidente
de la asamblea nacional y con varios de
los líderes de los grupos políticos de
la asamblea nacional todos ellos también
van a aislarse y justamente el día de
ayer no solamente había cenado con el
primer ministro ron castex que por ahora
pues ha dado negativo sino también con
el primer ministro de portugal antonio
costa quien está a la espera del
resultado del texto que se le hizo y
pues también de todas maneras va a
aislarse de manera preventiva y el
último es digamos en esta lista porque
prácticamente con el coach pues es como
en un efecto dominó es asia o michel el
presidente del consejo europeo quien no
es considerado como un caso contacto él
estuvo en compañía del presidente marco
el lunes pero que de todas maneras
también va a
aislado de manera preventiva la agenda
del presidente manuel marco ha sido
completamente cambiada luego de este
diagnóstico la semana próxima el debía
viajar al líbano para pasar con
militares franceses la navidad todo esto
pues hasta ahora claramente ha sido
cancelado natalia y le pregunto también
por el proceso por el fallido ataque al
tren thalys en 2015 porque hoy se conoce
el veredicto
así eso es un veredicto que debe
conocerse sobre las cuatro de la tarde
-hora local- los cuatro sospechosos
perdón los cuatro acusados van a dar
unas últimas palabras a la corte antes
de dar antes de que se conozca
precisamente este veredicto hay un
acusado principal que es ayub el kazan y
que es precisamente este hombre el que
estaba al interior de este tren está
lista y para quien se ha pedido cadena
perpetua y para los otros tres indicados
aquí en este caso pues se pidieron penas
que van desde los 8 hasta los 30 años de
cárcel habrá que esperar que decide esta
corte hay que recordar que estos hombres
en ningún momento se conocieron pero si
tenían una persona en común un conocido
en común y ss de la vida abajo de quién
es el hombre que habría cordón ha
coordinado todos los ataques terroristas
que se realizaron en francia entre ellos
el del 13 de noviembre
natalia muchas gracias por toda la
información estaremos muy pendientes de
estas dos noticias en francia volvemos
con información sobre el coi 19 porque
la presidenta de la
misión europea ursula von der leyen
informó que la inmunización en el bloque
iniciará el próximo 27 de diciembre
siempre y cuando la agencia europea de
medicamentos apruebe la vacuna de los
laboratorios pfizer y bayonne tec el día
21 la unión europea informó que
concluyeron las conversaciones
preliminares con el laboratorio novavax
para asegurar 200 millones de dosis de
su candidata a vacuna
de europa vamos a eeuu porque volvió a
romper su récord de casos muertes y
hospitalizaciones en las últimas 24
horas las autoridades indicaron que el
aumento es el resultado de los viajes y
reuniones durante la celebración del día
de acción de gracias a fines de
noviembre asimismo advirtieron que es
clave tomar medidas adicionales para
evitar que el virus se siga propagando
en navidad' en las próximas horas una
comisión de asesores de la
administración de drogas y alimentos se
reunirá para evaluar la vacuna
desarrollada por moderna que podría
recibir la autorización de emergencia en
los próximos días
las últimas cifras son asombrosas según
los medios de comunicación
estadounidenses se registraron alrededor
de 200.000 nuevos casos y más de 3.500
muertes en eeuu en las últimas 24 horas
los ángeles el condado más poblado de la
nación es el más afectado every hour
cada hora en promedio dos de nuestros
vecinos familiares o amigos mueren a
causa de colitis
con el número de personas hospitalizadas
por kobe 19 x casi 6 desde noviembre los
funcionarios de salud están instando a
la gente a no reunirse durante las
vacaciones de fin de año para detener la
cadena de contagios
estamos viendo el impacto de lo que pasó
en el día de acción de gracias parece
que no hay suficiente gente que haya
escuchado y seguido el mensaje de
quedarse en casa y evitar reunirse con
otro adders en california los hospitales
están al límite de sus capacidades sólo
el 4% de las uci están disponibles
somos extras hay tanto estrés en
nosotros las enfermeras y los médicos y
todos los trabajadores de la salud están
realmente trabajando tan duro a través
de esto
horas y horas y horas por día sin parar
'non stop' el despliegue de las vacunas
ha proporcionado un rayo de esperanza el
primer lote de 29 millones de dosis de
la vacuna facer variante que comenzó a
ser administrado a los prioritarios el
lunes se espera que una segunda vacuna
de moderna gane la aprobación de uso de
emergencia de la administración en los
próximos días las autoridades
advirtieron a los ciudadanos que no
bajen la guardia en menos de un año el
nuevo coronavirus ha infectado a casi 17
millones de personas en estados unidos
lo que equivale al 5% de la población
y finalizamos en brasil el tercer país
del mundo más afectado por la pandemia
superó los 7 millones de casos justo el
día en que el presidente de yair
bolsonaro presentó su plan de vacunación
el programa aún no tiene fecha de inicio
pero el gobierno asegura que permitirá
inmunizar a los 210 millones de
brasileños en apenas 16 meses veamos el
informe de álvaro cordero
brasil superó los 7 millones de casos
confirmados de copy 19 y se mantiene
como uno de los países más golpeados por
el coronavirus al acercarse también a
los 184 mil fallecidos cifras
preocupantes que coincidieron con la
presentación del plan de vacunación de
jair bolsonaro un plan ambicioso que
pretende vacunar a todos los brasileños
en poco más de un año pero que todavía
no tiene fecha en nyc
tenemos una agencia nacional sanitaria
que siempre ha sido un referente para
todos nosotros y sigue teniendo un papel
fundamental en la decisión de que la
vacuna se debe entregar de forma
gratuita y voluntaria a todos los
brasileños de forma gratuita y
voluntaria para todos los placeres a
pesar de que brasil tiene cerca de 200
millones de dosis aseguradas los
retrasos en la vacunación están
provocando auténticas disputas políticas
elpresidente bolsonaro ha confiado casi
únicamente en las dosis de astrazéneca y
la universidad de oxford pero el
gobernador de sao paulo ha apostado por
la china de sinovac asegurando que podrá
empezar a vacunar en enero
en marzo como algunos creen que empezará
en el resto del país la compañía china
ya envió un segundo cargamento a este
estado pero todavía no existe ninguna
autorización es esta situación ya está
generando inmigración entre parte de la
población
si brasil empieza a actuar ahora lo que
no está pasando entonces puede que
tengamos esperanza pero ahora es muy
complicado estamos muy atrasados en las
negociaciones de vacunas otros países ya
han comenzado las vacunaciones por lo
que es muy complicado en total brasil
espera adquirir 260 millones de dosis de
astrazéneca que se sumarán a los 40
millones de kóvacs a la espera de cerrar
acuerdos con más compañías
pinta el informativo y recuerden que
pueden ampliar toda la información en
nuestra web france24 puntocom regresamos
en breve con más noticias
[Música]